how's our day going so far now that
you've seen the episode everything that
went down how are you feeling
um I honestly I feel fine
um obviously we we filmed this back in
May so I've had the last few months to
process it
um and I feel like just as you heal you
get to re-watch it on TV which is great
um but I honestly feel fine I I Was
preparing for the worst and I found last
night's episode pretty funny so yeah
yeah well that's that's a great attitude
to have honestly okay so I have to ask
and I don't know if you've been asked
this already but the beads like the
whole thing with the beads did you have
any clue that Cody was working on
gaining this immunity idol like was it
not fishy that he was asking everyone
for these beads I had no idea and
honestly if anyone else had just
randomly weaved a hat and then said oh I
want to bedazzle it now I would have
been like what that's really weird but
character or Cody is such a character
that like we didn't think anything of it
for him to be doing that we were like
yeah like obviously you saw me I was
like yeah take mine sure like I was in
full support of him be dazzling his hat
but obviously I found out eventually
that that's how the beware advantages
work for my season and I was just like
wow that honestly is genius
I thought the exact same thing I was
like this is crazy I also didn't think
he was going to pull it off I was like
there's no way
um so yeah but then I have to know so it
seemed like
after the immunity Challenge and NECA
like not really pulling her weight from
what we saw and just kind of standing
around it seemed like you and Noel who
are close we're going to both be writing
down her name so then at the end I was
surprised to know that you voted for
Cody so like what made you put his name
down instead of knickers yeah and that's
something that they don't really show in
the edit is that at this point Dwight
was 100 with me and Noel he was in our
circle of trust um obviously he had lost
his vote so we needed to pull in Jessie
um Jesse was someone who up until this
point was actively playing both sides
um so yeah he was in the middle but like
he was
um you know strategizing with Cody and
NECA coming back to me and Noel and
saying like Okay this is what they said
like I think we should do x y and z
um and so we definitely thought that
Jesse was with us
um and we thought that NECA probably
knew that she was on the bottom so much
so that she might play her shot in the
dark and so you know Dwight doesn't have
a vote that would mean that NECA didn't
have a vote that means that me uh Noel
Cody and Jesse's votes count so in the
case that NECA were to play her shot in
the dark and be successful at it we
wanted Cody to go home and so that's why
we split our votes oh yeah they don't
really explain that so A lot of people
are like
Justina Noelle can't even figure out
their votes and we're like no there was
a plan but they don't really feel that
yeah they didn't show that at all but
that's really interesting to know so was
there a reason that you like was that
the reason that you didn't play your own
shot in the dark absolutely yeah I like
we were so confident that Jesse was
Voting with us
um and that NECA was going home if I had
any inkling going into Tribal Council
that that wasn't the case I absolutely
would have played my shot in the dark
absolutely so you mentioned well Jeff
mentioned in the episode that trust is
really the only currency in Survivor
despite everything else do you feel like
your trust was broken by Jesse
absolutely but there was also a large
part of me that didn't trust Jessie and
I learned from this situation to just
always trust my gut
um and to go with your gut because what
you also don't see from the edit was
there were countless times throughout
the day on that Friday my last day where
I turned to Noel and I was like are we
sure that we trust Jessie and I would
turn to Dwight and I'd be like are we
sure that we trust Jesse and they'd both
be like we're good like we are totally
good like everyone's sticking to the
plan
um but I should have listened to my gut
yeah well honestly it played out how it
did and it's really interesting kind of
all the Insight that you're giving me
like as a big Survivor fan I love
hearing this stuff and it's so
interesting to hear the inside yeah I
know it's it's interesting to experience
it because I was obviously a big
Survivor fan going into this but like
you obviously know that they're
condensing you know two or three days
into one episode so there's a lot that
you're missing
um and you only have what you're seeing
on screen to go off above so yeah it
isn't it's interesting seeing how they
edit it yeah absolutely and so circling
back to the immunity Challenge and NECA
and the performance that she did what
was the vibe like after that challenge
at camp like
what was the energy like
the energy was not good
um it was at an all-time low for sure
um we had gotten so used to winning from
those first two challenges that we
thought that we could just keep up a
winning streak
um and just avoid going to Tribal
Council uh and I'm super competitive
um and so I me and Noel were both kind
of pissed coming back to
um Camp because we had lost
um and in my opinion Survivor is not the
type of game where everyone takes equal
accountability
um you know it just wasn't that scenario
for me
um and I think people can choose to see
it in different lights I think some
people can probably jive with what Cody
said of like you know it's all of our
faults like anyone could have made that
mistake to not take the puzzle piece out
of the bag and I think that some people
can probably jive with what me and
Noelle were saying which is you know you
have to take accountability if you
volunteered to do the puzzle and you
forgot to take the piece out of the bag
that's on you
um so it depends on how you see it but
yeah I mean the the energy was very low
it was a very like somber couple hours
before tribal yeah absolutely and I
totally agree with everything that
you're saying
um also you mentioned at Tribal Council
that Cody was really the only person you
hadn't talked a lot of game with do you
wish Looking Back Now that you would
have taken more initiative to to talk to
him and talk game with him or do you
think what you did was kind of the right
way to go about yeah I mean hindsight is
20 20. there are a million things I
would have done differently
um I will say that I knew and you can
even see on the screen that like I was
pretty much a target for Cody since day
one
um and I could sense that I could feel
them looking at me and obviously they're
not talking to me so I felt like okay
they're they they don't really like me
um they don't really have a reason to
keep me they're not trying to get to
know me
um I could have done better at
neutralizing that and yeah trying to
create more of a bond with Cody but at
the same time I didn't know that Cody
was like talking this much much strategy
um with Jesse and with NECA I I honestly
half the time thought that he was just
out there for fun because you see him
like jumping off of rocks and yeah like
crazy stuff
um and so I I honestly didn't know what
to make of Cody out there but absolutely
I should have tried harder with him yeah
I think he shocked me a lot too because
initially kind of looks like chaotic
he's jumping off rocks running around
but he's actually like plotting a lot
had a lot more going on than I thought
yeah absolutely and I think from a
viewer's point of like point of view
that we all saw that too
um so would you say that within the vati
tribe like Cody is kind of running the
game like in that tribe would you say or
is someone else kind of taking the reins
um I mean I think if I were to be
watching this as just a completely
unbiased audience
um I would think that Jesse was running
it more than Cody because I think Jessie
put it pretty well at the beginning of
last night's episode where he was like I
would use Cody I'm not worried about him
um and I think that Cody has gotten a
lot of like confessionals and you get to
know him and like see like the inner
workings of his brain over the last two
episodes but
um sometimes people like that you know
kind of go out in a like flame as well
it's all completely reliant on you know
your strategy and and honestly luck so
it's it's hard to tell like who's
running it but if I were to watch it
back I would think that Jesse was over
Cody interesting I like that perspective
um so to wrap things up your Survivor
Journey came to a close last night is
there anything you would change about
your experience on the show
yes there were a lot of things I would
have changed
um I mean like obviously I would have
um tried harder neutralizing Cody
um I had no idea that he was targeting
me and I had no idea it was purely
because of sales and who knows if that's
legit or not or if it's you know
something deeper I have no idea
um but yeah I mean there are a million
things I would have done differently I
would have played my shot in the dark
but I try not to think that way because
what happened happened and I can't go
back and change anything
um I've accepted that my Survivor
Journey came to an end earlier than I
expected and I'm okay with that I love
the positivity that's the best way to
look at it well thank you so much for
chatting with me it was lovely talking
to you and enjoy the rest of the season
thanks Alyssa